they're starving pizza yes we deserve it
you aren't ordering takeout are you yeah
I just bought all those groceries there
is plenty of food here so much effort
you know Thai food pretty sure it'll be
cold by the time it gets here sure with
that attitude yes I like a better cold
all right you know what whatever I'm
pulling the trigger okay if this
delivery minimum is pretty steep for one
person I'm good just go walk to pick it
up Debbie brain bubble stay with me or
you could add an appetizer drink and
dessert could stick to that diet that
you've been preaching about on Instagram
for a while now I own I got it right
here sushi I'm having sushi no delivery
fee 1.7 miles away no it's always
undercooked I'll be hungry again in an
hour
okay I'm gonna starve to that fat we're
going back to pizza I am ordering pizza
so what are the cheap pizza which will
take what 25 minutes to get here or you
can order the good pizza that will take
roughly 90 minutes regardless of what
time you guys I am so hungry
sure yeah where were you thinking not
full smiley face emoji but like though
that one scent all right you got a why
not sell any special drumroll please
Michelle my Belle all right drum roll
butter I'm up with something Michelle
your chili well dry maybe just Applebee